المترجم: Mhd Adnan Ayasso
المدقّق: Fatima Zahra El Hafa
عندما كنت ألتقط صوراً لأم قمر في دروس
محو الأمية بالقاهرة، قالت لي
"يا أستاذة لورا، أريد أن أقول
لحضرتك أمرًا ما"
"أنا أحب الأفلام الأجنبية وأنت تذكرينني
بجاكي شان"
(ضحك)
لا يوجد هاشتاج جاكى شان اليوم.
أكيد أن موضوعنا اليوم ليس أفلام جاكى شان
الموضوع هو عن مشروع التصوير
الذي أعمل عليه منذ سنة 2009
ويحكي وينقل قصص نساء من المنطقة
وكيف أثرالتعليم على حياتهن.
وبنفس الوقت يوضّح المشاكل التى
واجهوها في تحصيل علمهم
عندما سألت أم أحمد من عمّان كيف أثّرت
دروس محو الأمية على حياتها
قالت لى "تخيلى الشارع الذيكنت أمشي عليه
كل يوم منذ ثلاثين سنة
"بدأ يعطي معنى مختلف في اليوم الذي استطعت
قراءة يافطات المحلات وإشارات الشارع"
لا شك أنّ التعليم متوفر لكتير من الناس.
من الممكن أننا نأخد التعليم بشكل مضمون
ولا ننتبه إلى التفاصيل الصغيرة
التي بإمكانها تغيير حياة شخص
إذا توفرت له هذه الفرصة
سناء من مصر.
التحقت بدروس محو الأمية لأنها
تتوه في المواصلات
أم العز رفضت أن تقول لها عائلة زوجها
أنّها جاهلة.
وإجلال شعرت بالإحراج عندما أحضر لها ابنها
رسالة من المدرسة ولم تستطع قراءتها
لدى الدول العربية مجتمعة نسبة أمية
مرتفعة وتحديدا للمرأة.
ومن هنا بدأت فكرة المشروع
اسمه "أنا أقرأ، أنا أكتب"
لتسليط الضوء على أهمية تعليم المرأة
حتى يكون لها دور أكبر في عملية التغيير
التي تشهدها المنطقة حاليا
وتحديدًا في الوقت الحالي
وانطلاقا من رغبتى بأن أغطي أكبرعدد ممكن
من الدول العربية كان من الضروري التركيزعلى
الاختلاف فى التعليم بين دولة وأخرى
لذلك فى كل بلد زرته، ركّزت على موضوع معين
يعنى بتعليم المرأة وهو بنفس الوقت موجود
فى كل بلد ولكن بنسب مختلفة
من برامج محو الأمية لإتحاد الطلبة فى
الجامعات إلى برامج المتسربات من المدرسة
وإصلاح التعليم. النساء اللاتي صورتهن
شاركن أيضاً في المشروع
من خلال الكتابة بخط أيديهن على الصورة
والإجابة عن أسئلة مختلفة تعبّرعن
آرائهم وأفكارهم
نادية من مصر.
التحقت بدروس محو الأمية لأنها تعبت
من فيديو كليبات نانسي عجرم
وتريد قراءة الجريدة.
(ضحك)
أسماء من تونس.
هي خريجة هندسة حيوية.
قالت لي أنّ حلمها كان قبل الثورة التونسية
أن تكتشف بكتيريا جديدة
الآن وبعد الثورة قالت لي أنّ حلمها تحقق
وصار هناك يوجد بكتيريا جديدة كلّ يوم
(ضحك)
لأن مشاكل التعليم كبيرة ومختلفة كان من
الضرورى أن تكون النساء اللاتي صورتهن مصدر
إلهام لغيرهن ورغبة منهنّ بنقل رسالة معينة.
خيزران هى مدرّسة من اليمن.
هناك مثل فى اليمن يقول
"البنت ليس لها إلّا الزوج أو القبر"
كتبت على صورتها تحديدا
"أنا تعلمت لتغييرهذه النظرة في المجتمع."
العادات والتقاليد هي إحدى
الأسباب التي تمنع البنات
من أن يبدؤوا تعليمهم أو حتى يكملوه.
هناك خوف الأهل إذا كانت المدرسة
بعيدة عن البيت.
وبعض الأهالي يرفضون إرسال بناتهن
إلى المدرسة
إذا تواجد مدرّس يعطي الدروس وليس مدرّسة
والمشكلة أنه فى بعض المناطق
لا يوجد عدد كاف من المدرّسات.
وللأسف لدى بعض الأهالي تلك العقلية
أنّ البنت لا داعي لتعليمها
لأنها غدا ستكبر وتتزوج
والزوج سيتكفل بكلّ شيء
فايزة من اليمن.
اضطرت أن تترك المدرسة منذ أن
كان عمرها ثمان سنين
حتى تتزوج
وتطلّقت بعد سنة
بعمر ال14 عادت وتزوجت مرة تانية من رجل
عمره 62 أو 63 سنة وصارت زوجته الثالثة
بعمر ال18 عادت وتطلّقت مرة ثانية
مع 3 أولاد
بالرغم من ظروفها الإجتماعية الصعبة
ومعارضة أهلها لرجوعها إلى المدرسة
وبالرغم من كونها مطلّقة فى مجتمع
محافظ جدًّا
كانت فايزة متأكّده أنّ المخرج الوحيد
لوضعها أن تكمل تعليمها
استطاعت الآن الحصول على منحة من جمعية
فى صنعاء وهي تدرس التجارة
هدفها أن تتخرج من الجامعة لتجد وظيفة
وتستأجر بيتا وتحضر أولادها حتى يعيشوا معها
الفقر وعبء التكاليف هما مشاكل
بعض العائلات
وإذا توفرالمصروف يفضلون أحيانا
تعليم الصبي على البنت.
وفاء من الأردن اضطرت ترك المدرسة
بالرغم من تفوّقها
حتى تبقى في البيت وتساعد أمها
بتربية أخواتها وتنظيف البيت
حاليا هى منتسبة لبرنامج للمتسربات
من المدرسة
والذي يعتبرفرصتها لتكمل تعليمها
أختها غيداء أيضا في نفس البرنامج
وحلمها أن تصبح شرطية
تركت غيداء المدرسة بسبب المعاملة السيئة
من المدرسات لها.
أساليب التعليم القديمة والتي فيها
إساءة لفظية وجسدية.
تدفع الكتير من التلاميذ إلى عدم إكمال
تعليمهم
بالإضافة إلى أنّ مناهج التعليم الحكومي
ما زالت لا تساعد الطالب على النقد والتحليل
مازالت تعتمد على نظام أنا أحفظ دون فهم
ويشعرالشخص أنّ أهمّ شىء
أن يحفظ الطالب الإجابة
حتى ينجح بالإمتحان.
شمس من تونس
هى طالبة لغة إنجليزية
ناشطة سياسية
هى وزملائها بالجامعة ينظمون حلقات نقاش
لنشر التوعية السياسية بين زملائهم
عندما التقيتها منذ سنتين، قالت لي
أن هدفها كان أن تصبح مدرّسة
حتى يكون عندها أثرعلى تلاميذها
وفعلاً هذا ما حدث.
بالنسبة للكتير من النساء اللاتي التقيتهنّ.
التعليم فى حد ذاته لم يكن الهدف
ولكن هو وسيلة حتى يصلوا لهدفهم.
مثل أم أحمد من الأردن وهي تمازحني عندما
سألتها لماذا قررت أن تتعلم وهي بعمر متقدّم
قالت لي "حتى أعرف أستخدام الفيسبوك
وأجد عريس"
(ضحك)
قلت لها" وكيف تريدين أن يكون شكل العريس؟"
فأجابت صديقتها التي بجانبها
"تحبه صغير وأشقر وعيونه زرقاء"
(ضحك)
أو مثلاً أمّ السعد من مصر
عندما سألتها "كيف هي الدروس؟"
ضحكت وقالت لي" أنّ زوجها حزين منها"
"ويهدّدها أن تبقى فى البيت لأنّه
اكتشف أنها تقرأ"
الرسائل النصية على جهازه المحمول."
(ضحك)
عائشة، مدرسة من اليمن
كتبت على صورتها
"تعلمت حتى لا أعتمد على الرجل
بكل شىء فأحسّ بإستقلاليتي"
عندما بدأت المشروع
كانت مصر أول بلد زرته وركزت فيه على
برامج محو الأمية التي مدتها تسعة أشهر
كنت متصورة ومقتنعة أنني سألتقي
بنساء هدفهن ّالوصول لأعلى مراحل التعليم
لكنّ الواقع مختلف كليّا
النساء اللاتي التقيت بهن، قرروا تعلّم
القراءة والكتابة بالرغم من ظروفهن الصعبة
حتى يسهلوا حياتهن اليومية.
لكني لاحظت شيئًا مشتركا بينهنّ وهو
إصرارهنّ وتصميمهنّ أن تكمل بناتهنّ التعليم
مسؤوليتنا نحن الآن أن نحسّن من التعليم
إلى الأفضل من أجل أولادنا.
إلى حال أفضل بكتير من المدارس
التي ذهبنا نحن إليها.
شكراً